olavo diz pessoal de quem fala em mudar
que sejam muito bem vindos de mais um
pedido o estrago já que dani é silente
onu ea maré simula ter nos mantido no
cargo de molin sabe aquela sala falou do
orgulho que eu tinha visto um episódio
anterior pois é nessa só vocês podem
ficar o demônio obrigada a quem explicou
isso nos comentários do vídeo anterior
vamos lá ninguém porque não tinha
ninguém lá não pôde continuar burro não
quer saber de que eu sou macho hofmman
eu estou no meu quarto outra vez que não
virava cascais na escola e supostamente
jogadores o dia 4 de abril e estou a
dizer isto porque porque nós temos aqui
uma personagem nova que eu não sei quem
é é uma professora de física é será não
fala comigo mas tem uma grande
personalidade mas vamos levando de jogar
ninguém é gente ter esse benefício para
este grand não vamos lá então ao que
interessa o que posta de novos que é
isto ação que elas vão destruí pop ou
não aqui uma bruxa a nelson vários
cursos só tem custo gráficos karaté
custo de rodas agora já não lembro onde
que é saúde o ritual emocional e não não
ela é só do território é o pedro me tem
como é e até é que esse comportamento
faz e judiciário nos comentários foi que
o tanque tirar essa faca daqui tem que
matar as pessoas que não existem ainda e
colocá los dentro deste circo e aí sim
você tenha transportado para o inferno
qualquer coisa assim eu não sei se isso
vai resultar mas eu confio em você já é
ninguém nessas estael israel ainda mais
não poder com faca ninguém anda assim na
escola para 1 de agosto no parque
eu acho que isso mostra o que eu posso
fazer entretanto é procurar a serra
elétrica que eu vou fazer agora agora eu
não sei como é que eu vou sair daqui
pelo próximo disseram ela tá quebrou um
jejum que a cena que fora pois para o
jardim é sempre fora depois só paisagem
bonita nuvem é este o jardim é isso tem
aspecto jardim o labirinto por um
labirinto também não é que é mesmo um
labirinto é mesmo o botafogo não eu não
vou entrar aqui que vamos primeiro já
saí há é que está a jogar assim pra mim
a aí que está o jardim supostamente jato
ouvir algumas plantações numa estufa é
isto
mesmo assim já está pronto a saltar com
uma textura gostando ok onde é que fica
a [ __ ] da serra serra de que taxas não
falam das coisas falar com elas a de
estar aqui dentro desta cozinha ataque é
isto circular só sabem por que as terras
não tem inimigos porque eu estou sempre
soft rock já tem material que é preciso
agora vamos lá pra sala do ritual
aconteceu ali porque os tipo votaram um
pau pra mim ficar falando o culto será
perdido ainda está a falar cala boca o
pessoal agora é agora estamos prestes a
matar o pessoal estamos prestes a
cumprir aqui
o ritual é morto não vai fugir é que nem
o dunga fugiu
acho que só com essas pessoas funciona
eu não sei mas vou tentar
o jato em motos e canela e saiu de moda
assassino não é para encher você já
tomou sustos além de desafiar as leis da
física e estamos em mim é e segue
coitada ela não usa o windows vista
aí a professora apanhou mil deu não faz
a professora vilma tentou matar a
professora já que tá aqui eu não tenho
um monte de estela
rio - conforma-se isso sentem sair agora
vamos fechar a cortina e agora vamos
tentar matar sem que ninguém vai ser
porque não a professora vai me banhar me
beijar
ai vai sofrer um tiro frontal no rio
tacutú não preciso me preocupar agora o
que eu vou fazer eu vou ter que estava
estudando e privatas fora do circo é da
capa dentro é isso aí tava com desta vez
ninguém fugiu eu acho que a professora
não vem atrás de mim porque supostamente
aquilo foi quem diz a professora estava
que acontecer coisas pra normais não se
expôs janeiro a faca o chute cruzado
acertou mas eu vou tentar pôr a faca
usada certa ao que já está tudo aqui no
maio e agora vamos ter a faca aqui ó
juntou aconteceu qualquer mil deu só fui
perguntar durante o 8º faca é expressa
que o caso dos que querem nuvem sabem
aqui o angel nomes vamos falar que
queremos ver que eu estou a falar dos
braços no vindos quer dizer que vou ter
que usar até agora é isso é isso agora
que o povo é isso ainda bem que eu
entrei se usará sérgio primeiro é esse
mesmo jogo desta terça arquiteto diz
rangel montar a área e olha que o
twitter não sai não fosse dentro do que
tem que fazer com ela dilma e nos
comentários pessoal nos com este
trabalho aqui eu saio de uma pista que
eu vou te contar aquelas pessoas todas
ali dentro do circo começa agora e se
amanhã o preço nem sei que aqui aparece
para falar com elas
a bolsa o rio só queriam ok eu tenho que
fazer qualquer coisa para ter o poder de
web isso será que basta tipo arrancar os
braços aquelas pessoas que eu não sei
mas vou tentar isso ok
como é que o corpo de moju é um tutorial
alguma coisa aí não é divertido cortar
pessoa fund normal pra mim é isso faço
dito o taco e brancos explodir estrutura
a gente né isso aí é a hora que está
pensando é em que saibam tocar no braço
quando mil estebes a wii e nem nos
comentários pessoal só sejam capazes de
fazer isso na nossa escola tiesto não
cabe na cabeça de ninguém mas vamos lá
continua a faltar um faltou um caiaque
já terminamos não aconteceu nada pessoal
à pessoa lá pessoal eu finjo que fazer
disseram e não condicionada aos postos
21 e ficaram um ano mas não será que é
por eu ter tipo parte do corpo fora do
circo a falta de perna e agora já está
tudo tranqüilo irritou havel não
condicionada ainda o que eu estou
fazendo errado
ok pois é um tipo que pesquisar e agora
essa
sei que tem que fazer está a quatro de
tarde e por isso eu fui às aulas
normalmente pratica o avançar do tempo e
agora são 13 35 e agora vou esperar que
os que entrem dentro da sala e as quatro
da tarde vamos cortar los no meio e se
stão voltar eu não sei como fazer isto
juro que não só entra entra em explique
mas vamos lá o esta é uma pessoa nova o
que é isto
será que este que tem a este acto é isso
é este que tem que te lembrar é isso
mesmo isso mas ninguém vai fugir
ninguém vai ser a professora ninguém
efe o resto acabou pra quem já caiu
agora fernanda não foge ainda cá anda cá
vamos lá vamos lá pra dentro né da lapa
dentro anda lá por que vocês fazem do
ritual porque vai ficar aqui dentro e
agora vou ter que buscar o outro membro
do zé manel fico cnaa poeta lá pra mim
vocês querem estragar o rito melhor
agora vamos fechar a porta ninguém vai
prosseguir com este assunto com ninguém
para perceber que os mortos estão aqui
ninguém acha são quase quatro anos lava
rápido eu acho que já foi feito na gente
falta alguém a festa aqui né da equipa
dentro do círculo eu acho que vou fazer
tudo certo agora já cortar não faltam
aqui faltam uns para lá pela quarta tudo
tu nem cortava para superar ou não o fiz
tudo isso fez check ok quem vivemos é
com esta boa não só por ser irmão do
santa na água da faca em um software de
oldrões o portugal estamos a organizar
as coisas do mundo os meu deus estão a
realizar abriga importantes matar
pessoas e agora aparece o time to go a
dj tudo tudo tudo tudo repito estou
fazendo uma música épica só para não ter
que evitar folha que já a primeira
vítima é matuto mata professora mata
tudo vai embora até então as mesas ontem
que alguém ouve dizer que tem a equipe
ao jn nojo na classe star meninos
eu voltei à vontade com a consigna
fotografia joão olha só após matar
aquela pessoa que nem posso o eu não
junta à rua perto as pernas ficaram lá
como assim mais querer esta personagem
que eu matei ela tinha uma outra roupa
isto é mentira este jogo é uma mentira
meu estudo monitor choque roçam outra
gente que não é só uma que não dá pra
matar também não dá pra matar
vamos tirar uma fotografia da noite ruim
e é nesse lance vejam só que eu
encontrei aqui e eu tenho uma foto
enquanto lembrava sorriu de matar uma
quanto a foto como assim não não taka
vai né porque é que não seja tac não
quer um quer fotografia ataca mal não dá
não funciona então é isso ai vamos ficar
por aqui com isso espero que vocês
tenham gostado aqui do ritual o dado dos
frangos e já sabem como ninguém nos
comentários comentem nos comentários
comentei em baixo o que é que vocês
querem que eu faço aqui no andar e se o
leito e esse eu falei alguma coisa mas
há mais coisas pra fazer dentro do
ritual e com e psol que tem que fazer é
em quanto como affleck bonito fica mais
próxima